JAMIE CASAP: All right.
Welcome everyone.
I think we're good to go.
My name is Jamie Casap.
I'm part of Google for Education
team, the global education
evangelist.
I am joined here today by Woj.
ESTHER WOJCICKI: Woj.
JAMIE CASAP: Woj.
Ester Wojcicki,
who is the-- I want
to make sure I get
her title right.
She's the founder of the media
arts center at Palo Alto High
School where she's also, not
the co-founder, but the common--
ESTHER WOJCICKI: I am the vice
chair of Creative Commons.
JAMIE CASAP: Of
Creative Commons.
And Esther and I
had known each other
since 2006, 2007 when you first
were involved in what we were
doing at Google for Education.
So I want to start with
that, talk a little bit
about the beginning
when we just kicked off
Google for Education
stuff, whether it
was Google Apps for Education
or some of the tools
that we were using.
Your involvement with that
was critical because look
where we are today.
We have 40 million
users using Google Apps.
You were involved with
that at the beginning.
You've been involved with
what we've been doing
in education for a long time.
Talk a little bit
about that history.
ESTHER WOJCICKI:
Yes, I was really
excited to be here
today first of all,
because I've been around
Google for a long time.
As a matter of
fact, since Google
was a baby in Susan's garage.
And so in 2006, what it
was, it was just a team,
a Google for Education team.
It consisted of Cristin
Frodella and me.
And so what we tried
to do is figure out
like, what are we going to do
to get more teachers involved.
And since being a teacher,
oh, I have some ideas.
And so I went around the
country and put up these panels,
got panels, New York,
Chicago, got teachers,
brought them in, and then
try to figure out what
would be the best thing to do.
And then we started the Google--
all the Google Apps, basically.
So I actually was really lucky.
I got to pick what
I thought would
be a good app for teachers.
Only thing that got removed
was I Google got slammed.
JAMIE CASAP: And we got a lot of
backlash for that at the time,
so we won't go there.
So let's talk-- you've been a
teacher for 30 plus years now.
ESTHER WOJCICKI: Yes, long time.
JAMIE CASAP: A long time,
and you're teaching students
at Palo Alto High School.
You've just opened
up, last year right,
the media center
at Palo Alto High.
Talk a little bit about
what you do at Palo Alto.
Talk a little bit about your
experience as a teacher there.
And then I want to show some
slides of the new media center.
But first kind of
tee it up with your
experiences as a teacher at Palo
Alto, how things have changed
over those last 30 years.
ESTHER WOJCICKI: OK, so when I
first to Palo Alto High School,
there was one small
class of students.
There were 19 kids
in the program.
We had a typewriter.
And the kids used to
write their stories up
and then they would type
them up on a typewriter.
Then I used to hand out
in class single edge razor
blades to everybody.
And they would cut their
story out and then paste it up
on a paste board with hot wax.
This was the way it was.
And then I always got really
mad because I would say,
it's crooked.
Got to get this thing straight.
And after three
years of doing that,
which was quite a
challenge actually,
the program had grown.
And I heard about these
things called computers.
I was like, oh my god,
something has to be better
than this typewriter.
And so that's the
beginning of what
happened with the computer.
I actually discovered a Mac
in Los Altos in a small store
and I applied for a grant,
the State of California,
and they told me, oh,
you'll never get it.
You have no idea how
to use this device.
And I agreed.
I didn't have any idea.
But, gutsy, I applied anyway.
And somehow or other the
State got-- I don't know.
Somebody made a mistake
and sent them to me.
And I got seven of them
and I didn't really
know how to use them at all.
And so then they were
in the back of the room,
all boxed nicely.
And I had to confess
to my students
that I had no clue
what I was doing.
And actually that
was the beginning
of my collaborative
teaching method,
because all my students got
super excited about this.
They showed up after school,
evening, weekends and we
figured out how to
work them together.
I never even knew what
the word network was,
but they showed me how to do it.
We did it all together.
So then for 30
years-- I probably
shouldn't give too
much detail on this.
For 30 years I
was in a portable.
JAMIE CASAP: Right.
I've been in that
portable with you.
I've visited.
ESTHER WOJCICKI: I know, a
portable, otherwise known
as a trailer, what was supposed
to be a temporary building.
And then the program
kept growing.
Everybody was like, what
is she doing in that class,
giving out pizza or something?
And actually the truth is,
I was giving out some pizza.
But there was more
to it than that.
So it grew and grew and
grew and pretty soon I
was in multiple portables
at the same time.
Kind of interesting
that the school
thought that I could
supervise multiple classrooms
at the same time
from one location.
JAMIE CASAP: How many
students are we talking about
at this point here?
ESTHER WOJCICKI: Oh,
at this point, well,
so it started with, I said, 19.
At that point I had
80 in one class.
So it was a ratio of one to 80.
So it was a little
difficult to control.
And not only that, they're
all over the place.
And my method of control
was very different
than other people's
method of control.
My method was, you're
going to be doing it.
I'll give you the tools and
now you take over and do it.
And so that's what enabled
me to have all these students
with just one teacher.
And actually the
interesting thing
is like, that freedom
and responsibility
is what attracted all
those kids to my program.
Everybody really
thought it was food,
but really it was freedom.
JAMIE CASAP: It's
food too, right?
ESTHER WOJCICKI: Well, food
and, yeah, that's true.
You did have the
food when you came.
JAMIE CASAP: It was good pizza.
So the media center opened.
ESTHER WOJCICKI: Oh yeah,
so then-- So fast forward
30 years, and the
school district
built this incredible
building for me,
25,000 square foot Media Arts
Center, Palo Alto High School.
It really is shocking.
Like I said, I went
from this trailer,
where actually the
roof was leaking
and a few other things like the
air conditioning didn't work,
into this thing which I
would consider a palace.
And you can see all
the different rooms.
It's got room for
every single program
that I created over the years.
And there's the atrium.
The reason they made
an atrium that big,
is because my classes
generally ran 80 kids.
And the question is, what are
you going to do with 80 kids?
Well, how about packing
them into this atrium.
And it turns out
that the kids prefer
to be-- they really like
to be sandwiched together
in smaller spaces.
So now they're all in these--
I have three other rooms.
And they sort of spread
out in those other rooms.
Although yesterday, they
were all in the atrium.
We have a lot of flexibility.
It's great.
JAMIE CASAP: And what it has
been your experience with this,
compared to being in those
trailers that you had before?
What's been your greatest
highlight from this experience?
And it's only been
open since when?
ESTHER WOJCICKI:
About eight months.
JAMIE CASAP: About eight months.
ESTHER WOJCICKI:
Since last August.
So the greatest experience--
I mean, it's just unbelievable
how excited the students are.
And one of the main
problems that we have is
get them to go home.
Nobody wants to leave.
As a matter of fact, that
was one of the things,
it's like, it's 5 o'clock
in the afternoon or six,
how many kids are
still in the building?
Can we ask them to go home?
And they are working
collaboratively,
so they actually
want to stay there.
That's just one that you just
had, that one computer lab.
That's one of three.
Back in the olden
days, in that portable,
I had a computer lab that I
had to share with other people.
Frequently that
computers didn't work.
And not only that,
I was supposed
to be in that room and
the computer lab, which
was, of course, on the
other side of campus
at the same time.
JAMIE CASAP: And all your
furniture is all movable
so you can create collaborative
spaces and teams can
set themselves up in different
corners of the space.
ESTHER WOJCICKI: You see
those desks right there?
They move.
And so kids, I can
say get into a group.
And they can all like, scoot
into a group in a minute.
So I don't believe
in desks and rows.
JAMIE CASAP: Are
they good for racing?
Can you race them?
ESTHER WOJCICKI: Well, actually
they have had some races.
We've had to control
it a little bit.
But in general, we
don't have rows.
We have kids working
collaboratively.
That is a picture of--
that was the grand opening
for the building.
It had three really amazing
people, Arianna Huffington,
and David Kelley
from the d.school.
And Shelby Coffey from the
Newseum in Washington, DC.
They had an amazing panel.
It was great and I'm
sorry we didn't record it,
unfortunately.
JAMIE CASAP: So let's talk
a little bit about what you
do in the Media Center right?
So in education, I think one
of the reasons why you're
highlighted in what
you do is because you
have this unique way of
controlling your kids, which
is not to control them right?
So talk a little bit
about what you do.
We hear a lot in education,
project-based learning,
blended learning.
What are these terms, what
do these terminologies mean?
How do you use this
in the classroom?
ESTHER WOJCICKI: So
blended learning,
I don't know how many of you
know what blended learning is,
but it really is an
opportunity to give students
more control of their learning.
So typical classroom--
as a matter
of fact, 80% of the
classrooms today, the teacher
still lectures 100% of the time.
And so the question is,
how effective is that?
And the answer really
for the most part,
is it's not very effective.
People, you know, they
daydream, they do other things.
It just doesn't really work.
And people learn by doing.
Tom Dewey said,
many, many years ago,
100 years ago to be exact,
that people learn by doing,
but unfortunately,
education takes a long time
to figure that out.
And so what I want my students
do and blended learning is,
is 50% of the time, they
are working on something
that's a project-based.
Actually in my classes
it's more than 50%,
but for the rest of the
nation, can they somehow
give students some opportunity
to control their learning?
That's the key.
Because the question is even
just here, working at Google,
how excited would
you be about what
you're doing if
somebody told you
what to do 100% of the time?
Nobody likes to be bossed
around all the time.
And that's what's
happening unfortunately,
in a lot of schools.
JAMIE CASAP: And I
think one of things
that people get surprised at,
we talk about blended learning,
we talk about
project0based learning
as having a product at the
end of your experience.
And I think a lot of times
when we think about student
projects, we think about the
volcano with tissue paper
or whatever.
But your students are
creating real stuff.
So I want to highlight
a couple of things,
if you can talk about
some of the things
that your students
are actually doing.
ESTHER WOJCICKI: So if you just
think about the teenage years,
kids want to be independent.
Isn't that it?
Number one, they want
to be independent.
As a matter of fact, if
they see a parent coming,
they usually cross the street.
I don't have any parents.
I was born kind of under
a rock or something.
That's typical.
Most kids want to
be independent.
It's not, of course, that
they don't love their parents.
It's just that it's
a time in life when
they're seeking independence.
So I try to build into that by
giving them the independence
to create these projects.
And the projects are real.
So this is "The Campanile."
It was founded in 1918.
It's the student newspaper
at Palo Alto High School
and it runs 28 pages,
three sections,
comes out every three weeks.
And it also has a
website and it also
how has a magazine
that goes with it.
JAMIE CASAP: And they go
through the same process
that any news organization will
go through, editorial board,
editors.
ESTHER WOJCICKI: Everything.
Not only that, they
support it themselves.
So one of the hardest
things for them to do
is to sell advertising.
They are terrified.
It's kind of interesting.
It's very hard.
But my idea is,
like I say to them,
no more Girl Scout Cookies.
You're no longer these
cute little things.
You're going to have to give
people value for whatever it
is they're paying for.
And you also have to
learn how to do this.
This is American society.
And so they do it.
So the whole thing.
This is "Verde Magazine."
I founded that in 2000.
And this is "C Magazine."
It comes out with
"The Campanile."
So they copied it from
"The New York Times."
As a matter of fact, doesn't it
look like "The New York Times"
a little bit?
And it comes out
every three weeks.
It's 28 pages,
full color glossy.
JAMIE CASAP: Oops, sorry.
ESTHER WOJCICKI: Go back.
So this is daily.
We broadcast daily
to the school.
We have closed circuit.
But it's also online, so
you can see it right away.
And you can see the archives.
The parents can see
what they're doing.
And this was founded in 2007.
The question was, how to
get all those guys that
don't want to learn to write?
Well, how are you going
to get them to write?
Well, the main thing they want
to do is play sports, right?
So the question is, what
are they interested in?
How about sports?
Let them write about each other.
And they loved it.
And so, it's a very
popular program
and it's a great
magazine and a website.
This is "The Voice."
This is a website, it's daily,
updated multiple times a day.
And they write about whatever
again, that's important.
So one of the
things we want to do
is give them the
responsibility to know
what it is that's
important to write about.
That is really hard
for most teenagers.
As a matter of fact, in the
beginning journalism class,
it takes me about 10
weeks to get them out
of the mode of
tell me what to do
to get an A. That's
all they want
to know, how do I get an A?
And it's a real
problem, because you
want to hire people
who actually think
for themselves, independent,
feel good about it,
willing to take a risk.
And you don't get that if
you sit in the classroom
and told what to do all the
time and worry about your grade.
JAMIE CASAP: Right.
And I think it's
important to highlight
these, because I think
most people would agree,
seeing these, you would think
that any professional publisher
were producing these, when in
fact, it's your high school
students that are doing this.
And I think that disconnect
between what is project-based
learning and what really
is project-based learning
is highlighted and
shown with the products
that your kids are producing.
ESTHER WOJCICKI: Right.
They make a difference
in their own community.
For example, we have a program,
a teacher adviser program,
where we got rid of
the counseling system.
And we have-- every teacher
has like, 60 students that they
act as a counselor-adviser to.
That came about as a
result of an article
in "The Campanile" newspaper.
And so they know
they're empowered.
It makes a difference.
And so they're
really interested.
JAMIE CASAP: And you can't get
rid of your students, can you?
ESTHER WOJCICKI: So this is
my class size, ratio 1 to 70.
And so the question
is, do I control them?
Well, the answer
is, they control
each other and themselves,
based on the learning
and based on the
philosophy in the program.
And I don't have problems
with kids cutting class.
As I mentioned, my
number one problem
is, can you please go home?
And we're happy you're here.
JAMIE CASAP: But
you want to go home.
ESTHER WOJCICKI: Yeah,
Mom and Dad miss you.
JAMIE CASAP: So
you wrote a book.
I don't know how you
found the time to do this.
I'm a little jealous
and I'm curious.
So we'll have more conversation
about how you actually
had time put all this together.
But let's talk about this.
Why did you write a book?
What's the message in the book?
What are you trying to
get across with this book?
ESTHER WOJCICKI: So
I wrote this book
because I'm trying to spread
this idea of how you can
do project-based learning
that is not, as you say,
you know volcanoes and I
don't know missions and things
like that, you know,
the mission project.
And because this is real world.
This makes an impact.
And so I wanted other
kids around the country
to have the same opportunity.
Because our dropout rate in
America today is about 40%.
And these people then
don't have skills.
So how can you engage kids?
They don't have to be like super
smart Palo Alto, wealthy kids.
They can be any kid.
I think no matter what
your income level is,
you want to be trusted,
you want to be respected,
and you want to be
given some freedom.
And so that's the goal.
JAMIE CASAP: Before we get
into some of meat of the-
ESTHER WOJCICKI: The book?
JAMIE CASAP: --the
book itself, let's
talk a little bit about
who wrote your forward
and how that came about.
ESTHER WOJCICKI: So
this is my forward.
It's written by James
Franco, the actor.
And the reason he
wrote the forward
is, he was my student
for three years.
He was in this program.
His high school was typical
of most student's high school
experiences, you know,
a little up and down.
And he bonded with the
program and with me
and he said that it was the
only place where he really
learned how important it was to
have a real world experience.
He wrote, and his articles, he
got feedback on his articles.
He was kind of shocked
that anybody read them.
And that he wasn't just
writing for some teacher, who
would then throws paper
into some circular file.
He was writing
for the real world
and it made a huge
impact on his life.
So he has written the forward.
He came back for
the grand opening.
And I invited some people
to come and turns out,
700 people came to see him.
It's a little more
than I expected.
And he was nice
enough to do a selfie
with every single person.
I couldn't believe it.
At the end of that
I thought he was
going to faint or something.
But he also made,
he drew or painted--
I don't know if you
know, he's an artist.
He painted all these gigantic
paintings for the building.
So if you come ever-- you're
all welcome, by the way.
--you'll see paintings
by James Franco.
And he did a great job.
JAMIE CASAP: And he
keeps coming back, right?
There's a bunch of art pieces
that are in the Media Center.
Like you need to build
a bigger building just
to keep his art work
that's in there, right?
ESTHER WOJCICKI: Well, yes.
He is coming back
often and actually he's
planning to come back
more often in the fall
for a special program that will
be announced a later point.
But I think hats off to him
for spending time and doing
this for the Palo Alto--
JAMIE CASAP: And also
highlighting the fact
that project-based learning
had a huge impact on his life,
in terms of being able to
see the process of being
able to get feedback and
collaborating with folks
and create something.
I think that had a
huge impact on him.
ESTHER WOJCICKI: Huge.
And then also the other
thing that he writes about
in this forward is how he's
now teaching a lot at UCLA
and another-- I think it's NYU.
And he uses this exact
model in his own teaching.
So that's a part of why
he wrote the forward.
JAMIE CASAP: So let's talk
about the meat of the book.
I think I have some slides.
Oh sorry, I was going to
show you the moon shot slide
here that you love so much.
This is you standing
there, right?
ESTHER WOJCICKI: No.
This is a statue, fortunately,
donated by my daughter, Anne.
It arrived the other
day, literally,
it's only a week there.
And boy, it's become
number one place to visit.
And to be honest,
I'm not quite sure
what she was doing with that
statue and how I got it.
JAMIE CASAP: Where she get--
the things you can find on eBay.
ESTHER WOJCICKI:
I have a feeling
that she had some
kind of a party
and now I've got the statute.
I'm not sure.
But anyway, my students
think it's great
and everybody's taking their
picture with the statue.
So whatever, it's great.
JAMIE CASAP: So one of
the big themes in the book
and what you're trying to get
across here is about control.
ESTHER WOJCICKI: Right.
JAMIE CASAP: And you
highlight-- and I can show you
some highlights here
about giving students
some control of their learning.
Talk a little bit
about what that means.
You highlighted that
a lot in the book.
What does that mean?
ESTHER WOJCICKI: So giving
students some control
their learning.
So I think it's really
difficult for teachers
to give students control.
Because you come out of
a school of education
and what happens is,
you've got this book.
I'm not kidding,
they give you a book,
how to maintain control
in your classroom.
Discipline, how to maintain--
yeah, how to achieve this.
JAMIE CASAP: I was going
to show some slides.
ESTHER WOJCICKI: There it is.
Those are just two examples.
But then show the next slide.
Just put this on.
That's just one of
150 million responses
you can get if you type in
control of your classroom.
Teachers are obsessed,
obsessed, with keeping control.
As matter of fact, they're--
and evaluated on the kind
of control they
have in the class.
So somebody comes in
the class and they
expect everybody to be
sitting there quietly,
quietly interacting with a
book or with a piece of paper
and listening to the oracle
speak, the teacher, right?
And so if you want to have
project-based learning
and if you want to give
some students some control
it looks very different.
It looks messy.
People are talking
to each other.
Just like you saw those chairs
I have, they're all in groups.
They're not all
lined up in a row.
It's not all symmetrical.
JAMIE CASAP: I would say that,
before The Media Center, when
somebody would want
to go visit you,
unlike a typical
classroom where you
knew exactly where the teacher
was, it took like 15 minutes
to find you.
Because you're somewhere in the
back working with some team.
Nobody could find
you at any point,
because it looked
like it was chaotic.
ESTHER WOJCICKI:
It looks chaotic.
But you know, some people ask,
so how are these kids doing?
Was their publication
good or how does it rank?
So just so you know, we
have won consistently,
for several years in a row,
the Gold Crown from Columbia.
So it's the top of the nation.
So it's not like
you're giving kids
control and all
of a sudden, they
start producing
low quality stuff.
It's just the opposite.
You give them some
control and then
they feel passionate
about what they're doing
and then they want
to make it the best.
So I think that's really true.
And finding me in the
classroom, that's right.
It was hard to find
me in the classroom.
So I was certified as
something called National Board
Teacher, National Board
for Professional Teaching
Standards.
And they require you to
have a video of yourself.
Here's another
problem, teaching.
And so you have to
stand up and lecture
and then they evaluate you.
And then they either
certify you or don't.
And that was the
biggest hangup for me.
I had to organize
a special day when
I could make them all sit
there and I could lecture
and they could all sit quietly.
JAMIE CASAP: You were
pretending like you were--
ESTHER WOJCICKI:
I was pretending
like this was my class.
So you see, it's embedded.
It's all over society.
And so, if we can
somehow get this idea
across that giving people
more freedom to learn,
even if they're in bodies
that are younger than 18,
will make a big difference
in their learning.
JAMIE CASAP: I want
to ask you a question,
and then as I do that, I want
to open it up for questions.
So if you have
questions to ask Esther,
there's a microphone up there.
So think about your
questions as I ask you this.
And then we'll have some
dialogue with the audience,
because they're here.
ESTHER WOJCICKI: That's great.
That's great.
JAMIE CASAP: If you're
talking to a new teacher
or if you're talking
to a teacher who's
been a teacher for five
years, doesn't really
matter, what is the moonshot?
What do you want
them to think about?
You want them to read
your book and you
want them to think about
very specific things
that they can do
in their classroom.
What's the big takeaway from it?
ESTHER WOJCICKI: So the big
takeaway is like, for example,
hopefully they'll
get Chromebooks.
We just got Chrombooks
for the school.
The first thing you want to
do is give them the Chromebook
and teach them how to search.
And search--
where's Dan Russell?
He was--
JAMIE CASAP: There he is.
ESTHER WOJCICKI: Dan.
Yes.
Thank you, Dan, because this
is the first thing that they
need to know how to do.
And then after that, you
give them an assignment
to do, for example, literally
anything, including math,
you know, science.
It's the entire curriculum
and you open it up.
Instead of you lecturing,
like for example,
even on Romeo and
Juliet, what's the story
behind Romeo and Juliet?
Well, how about
you guys go online,
take a look at what
the resources are.
What is the story
of Romeo and Juliet?
You have 10 minutes
to find out and then
I want you to talk to
each other in a group.
What is the story?
How did that come about?
I'll tell you, they're going to
learn more in that 10 minutes
than they would if I
spoke for 10 minutes
and told them the story.
They will not remember
anything I said.
They're probably
dreaming about what
they could do as soon as
they get out of school.
So that's part of, I
think, what's going on
and what they should be doing.
And I think one of
the things that Google
could do that would be helpful--
since all these publications I
do, by the way, there
are all done on Docs.
My hat off to the Docs team.
I couldn't do any of this stuff
without the collaboration.
They all peer edit everything.
That's the way it works.
And so one of the things
that would be great
is if somehow we could
get that message across,
that it's easier for
the teacher to teach
and more effective for
the students to learn,
if they would just
relinquish some control.
And as I said, if the
blended learning model could
be more effective
nationwide, we might not
have that 40% dropout rate.
You'd have more kids
that were engaged.
JAMIE CASAP: Questions.
What do we have?
We have Esther here.
Do we have some questions
from the audience?
AUDIENCE: Thanks for coming.
I've really enjoyed the talk.
You mentioned that you believe
that the blended learning
model can work in all
socioeconomic situations.
Do you have any examples of
maybe where blended learning
has been applied in the
lower socioeconomic kind
of neighborhoods or demographic
and the success rates?
ESTHER WOJCICKI:
You know, I don't
have-- I didn't personally
teach in any of those areas.
Although I can
say that last year
I volunteered to teach the
lowest lane at Palo Alto High
School, the majority of students
coming from East Palo Alto.
And it worked with them too.
And I was teaching
English in that program.
JAMIE CASAP: I can
add, the methodology
is being used by schools
all over the world, all
over the country.
There's a school in Philadelphia
called-- we could actually--
there's a school here
in California, High Tech
High, that uses project-based
learning and the zip codes
that kids come from are all
over the place in Southern
California.
There's a school in Philadelphia
called the Science Leadership
Academy, same thing.
It's an inquiry-based
high school.
It's all project-based
learning that they're doing.
So the model applies even
more so, I think, sometimes
in socioeconomic-- poorer
socioeconomic background
schools because you're
putting kids together
that have diverse backgrounds,
diverse perspectives
and they're creating some
unusual and cool things.
And so you're seeing a
lot of cool things come
from that in those schools.
ESTHER WOJCICKI: I think
it does work really well.
Those kids are so used to being
told what to do all the time
and being bossed around,
and so their idea
of using tech in the classroom
is to have a worksheet online.
And so you'll see kids
with those computers,
and you think they're
doing something creative.
Well, think again.
They are not.
They're just doing that same
thing, online worksheet.
JAMIE CASAP: Let
me ask you about--
did that answer your question?
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
JAMIE CASAP: So let me ask you
about professional development
for teachers.
What do you like about
professional development?
I almost didn't
want to ask that.
What would you change about
professional development
for teachers?
What's wrong in
that set up system?
ESTHER WOJCICKI:
Is there anybody
in here who has been a teacher?
So you remember what
professional development
is like?
So they bring in
some high paid guy
to speak to you at the
beginning of whatever day
it is, and they speak.
It's a lecture-based model.
And then they ask you
afterward to get together
in little groups and tell you
what you thought of that guy
that's spoke.
I would change that whole thing.
I mean, I would
have people actually
doing exactly what we
recommend in the classroom.
Teachers should
do the same thing,
put themselves
together in groups,
talk about issues
in their classroom,
find solutions, and then share.
It's kind of like the
unconference model.
You know the
unconference, like--
JAMIE CASAP: The unconference
model where it's self-driven
and the participants
are actually
driving the conversation, as
opposed to being lectured to
by someone who comes in.
ESTHER WOJCICKI:
That's right, yeah.
I mean I think lecture-based
works to a certain extent.
That's why I said, the
blended learning, 50%.
OK you come lecture for 50%.
But then after that,
you need to stop.
Cut it out.
JAMIE CASAP: What
skills do teachers
need to be able to implement
this model that they don't
necessarily have now or they're
not necessarily utilizing now?
ESTHER WOJCICKI: I
think the main thing
is they have to let go of
their fear of giving students
some control.
I mean, it looks
messy, it really does.
Kids will be talking
to each other.
They might not turn
their stuff in on time.
But after a short
period of that,
you're still collecting work.
You know, I collect
all the stuff online.
And then all corrected online.
But if you want, you can
collected in hard copy,
or you can get other
kids-- you know,
you're still doing
the same thing.
The only difference
is that you're
giving them more control.
You're not dictating
to such a degree.
And I think that as I mentioned,
the main thing that teachers
are afraid of is losing
control, because that's
what you're trained to do
in a school of education.
And that's what your
principal comes through.
They have this thing
called scripted teaching.
Are you familiar with
scripted teaching?
Anyone know about it?
It's right here in
Santa Clara County.
Scripted teaching is basically,
they give you a textbook.
They give you
exactly what you're
supposed to say
and tell you where
you're supposed to be on every
single day of the school year.
And they give you the tests too.
It's happening right now,
right here, as we speak.
And the question is,
how effective is that?
And I would say, it's
not very effective.
Doesn't seem-- we have
600,000 jobs that go unfilled.
Did you know that?
JAMIE CASAP: Uh, huh.
ESTHER WOJCICKI: And the
reason they go unfilled
is because they can't find
people with the right skills
to fill those jobs.
We're training for
a factory model.
And of course, as I mentioned,
in schools like in Oakland,
Oakland's dropout rate is 70%.
Did you guys know that?
Isn't that something
scary, I think?
San Jose actually has a pretty
high dropout rate as well.
JAMIE CASAP: So we had some
people lining up for questions.
And I have some others,
but I'll start up here.
AUDIENCE: So could you
talk a little about blended
learning for younger age groups?
ESTHER WOJCICKI:
That's a good idea.
JAMIE CASAP: That's
a good question.
ESTHER WOJCICKI: Yeah.
So you know, even little kids,
small kids, preschool kids,
even they like to work
together with their friends.
They're all coming to
school to see their friends.
If anybody's a teacher in here,
I don't want to disappoint you.
They're not coming to see you.
And the same thing happens
in elementary school.
So you want to give
kids an opportunity
to work in a peer group.
You can be more directive.
That's why I say even 50%,
but you can do the same thing.
Kids get excited about that.
It works in elementary
school as well.
There are some
subjects where I think
it's a little bit harder to
do it than in other subjects,
like for example, perhaps
science, chemistry.
Chemistry is so much
memorization and so forth.
But you can still have kids
doing a project based on that.
It's a lab science.
JAMIE CASAP: I think
the main point here,
and you and I have talked
about this in the past,
is that school was set up
as an individual sport.
But we live in a
team-based world, right?
And so we take kids through
this individual experience, even
young kids, and then we push
them out the door and we say,
OK, go work with others.
Good luck.
And we're not teaching
them that's skill set.
And project-based learning,
besides what they're producing,
is helping them create
that collaborative mindset
that we need in the work world.
Because what we don't
work in a factory
where one person's
doing one thing.
We're working in an
environment where
it's knowledge-based,
network-based, where we need
people to collaborate more.
ESTHER WOJCICKI: Right.
JAMIE CASAP: And
in your program,
kids are learning that, more
so than creating a newspaper,
they're learning how
to work with each other
and how to build off
each other's strengths
and those types
of things as well.
ESTHER WOJCICKI: I think a
lot of elementary schools
are already doing a lot of this.
There are more
into project-based
learning than the
high schools are.
I think the problem comes in
middle school and high school,
where they start to
really lecture full time.
And especially those AP
classes, AP US History,
90 minutes of lecture
all the time, constant.
JAMIE CASAP: For all those
AP history jobs, right?
ESTHER WOJCICKI: Yeah.
For all those AP
history jobs, yes.
AUDIENCE: I imagine
motivation, student motivation,
has a big effect
on blended learning
and I was wondering if you
could talk about motivation
and whether all students
react the same way
and whether that
affects performance.
And would you teach people that
are highly motivated or less
motivated the same way?
ESTHER WOJCICKI: It turns out
that this blended learning
motivates kids.
And so, I get kids that
are not at all motivated.
I mean, James Franco
was one of them.
And this can change the
way that they-- their life.
JAMIE CASAP: Because it helps
them build autonomy, right?
ESTHER WOJCICKI: It
helps them build autonomy
and also they become friends
with all the other kids
in the class.
It's a big community,
in essence.
It ends up being an
intellectual team.
There are now it's about 600
kids taking media arts studies
at Palo Alto High School.
You can imagine the
size of that team.
Its huge.
And they all feel connected.
It makes a huge difference to
how they feel about themselves
and how they feel about being
there at Palo Alto High School.
JAMIE CASAP: Yes, sir.
AUDIENCE: So as someone
who lives with a teacher,
I get to hear all the complaints
about the backwardness
of professional development and
the factory model all the time.
How would you suggest
a teacher going about
to create the changes that
you've been able to create
in their own schools?
Do they get lucky
with seven computers
or are there active steps
they can take to help
get the administration
on their side?
ESTHER WOJCICKI:
Well locally, I can
tell you there's going to be
a film on the 28th of April.
And it's just coming out and
it won Sundance Film Festival,
called, I think it's
called "How We Succeed."
We can't show any
films here, but I'll
be happy to send a link to that.
It's free.
I would advise--
JAMIE CASAP: Is this
"Most Likely to Succeed"?
ESTHER WOJCICKI: Oh it is
"Most Likely to Succeed."
JAMIE CASAP: Larry
Rosenstock at High Tech High.
ESTHER WOJCICKI: That's right.
"Most Likely to Succeed."
I'm trying to arrange
most faculties around here
to see that film.
They need to see it.
The administration
needs to see it.
Teachers need to see it.
It shows you how
to get it going.
Because a single teacher
in a school by yourself,
it's a real battle.
I mean I had a battle for years,
because I started doing this
when nobody else was doing it.
And people thought I was wacky.
I guess the only ones that
didn't think I was wacky
were all the parents
and all the students,
because the program
kept growing.
And they were like,
what's she doing in there?
Oh my god, they all look like
they're not doing anything.
They're just talking.
But I think it's
tough for your--
and I hear your wife
and her problems.
The PD is very difficult,
professional development
because it is mind-numbing.
JAMIE CASAP: So let's
talk a little bit
about-- let me ask
you a question,
what you just mentioned
about the movie,
"Most Likely to Succeed."
It actually highlights--
I saw the movie.
ESTHER WOJCICKI: Larry
Rosenstock at High Tech High.
JAMIE CASAP: It highlights
project-based learning
as a model and it
clearly points out
that you're not covering
all the material
but you're teaching kids a whole
bunch of new ways to learn.
One of the issues that you get
against project-based learning
or one of the
naysayers, if you will,
against project-based
learning is,
we need to teach to the test.
Assessments, talk a little
bit about assessments
and the negative impact that
potentially assessments have.
Not to lead the witness.
ESTHER WOJCICKI: OK, Jamie.
JAMIE CASAP: But also
like how do you get around
that idea of you have
to teach to the test
and you can't do
project-based learning.
ESTHER WOJCICKI: I still
think you're teaching.
That's the 50%.
You know you're still doing it.
The only thing is, the
teaching is sticking.
That's the difference.
So kids have a
reason why they're
learning all this stuff, as
opposed to just memorizing it
so they could take a test.
So these kids in this program,
in the media arts program,
they all score at the top.
I mean Palo Alto High
School and a lot of the kids
coming out of this program
are National Merit Scholars.
So most schools are
happy when they have one.
I think we have 50.
And it all comes because
it matters to them.
It's just like a
foreign language.
You learn something,
French or Spanish
or whatever, then you
don't practice it and then
where does it go?
When you go to France, you
can't remember anything.
So I mean this gives
them an opportunity
to practice every day.
So even if schools want to have
a six period day where there's
all lecture, if they could just
give them the seventh period
to have it for project-based
learning, that is meaningful,
it might make those other
six periods tolerable.
So I'm trying to think of
all these different methods
to get people to do it.
And that's the
purpose of the book.
JAMIE CASAP: I was going to
say, they're all in the book.
ESTHER WOJCICKI:
It's all in the book.
So the first part of the book
is the introduction of course,
by James Franco.
And then there's some
philosophy on like, why do it.
Why should you do it?
And then followed
by chapters on apps,
which apps can you use in
every single subject area,
followed by networks
for teachers.
How can you personally get
support if you need support?
There's networks.
And then the last part
of it is the history
of technology in America.
Like what has happened, since
we started with technology,
what's happened, what are the
statistics, how does it work?
And so, that's sort of how
to get it spread everywhere.
Fortunately, the book
has done pretty well.
So it's all over-- well,
it's sold out actually
at Kepler's and
Books Incorporated
and we're almost ready for
the second printing on this.
JAMIE CASAP: If there
was only another way
to get a copy of a book
into some kind of format.
ESTHER WOJCICKI:
Well, so look at.
This was published by
Pacific Research Institute.
They are a wonderful
group in San Francisco.
It's a think tank.
And they normally don't
really publish books.
They publish important
papers and things
from scholars and
things like that.
They're a little
shocked to be honest,
that this book has
already sold out,
and they're not quite
sure what to do.
So they are planning on
doing a Kindle edition.
They have never done a Kindle
edition for any book yet.
And so this is a first.
But they promise me it's coming.
So yes, Jamie, it's coming.
JAMIE CASAP: I've just been
giving her-- all right.
Yes, Tracy.
AUDIENCE: So Palo Alto has seen
a rash of some mental health
challenges and I imagine
that in your world,
in particular, as sort of
the voice of the school,
that you've seen a lot of how
the students are responding
to that.
And I'm curious to hear
your thoughts on both that,
but how you feel like
project-based learning
and blended learning
has impacted
the social and emotional
health of the kids as well.
ESTHER WOJCICKI: That's
a great question.
So for those of you
that aren't aware,
so Palo Alto schools,
especially Gunn High School,
has had a rash of suicides.
And these are high
achieving students,
apparently did not have
a lot of the factors
that people would suspect
them to be suicidal that
have committed suicide.
So we've had three in
the last four months.
And it's been pretty
bad, to be honest.
And I personally think that the
kids that were-- the factors
affected those kids
were expectations
that are kind of embedded
from the parents or maybe
the grandparents.
And that the kids
then embed those.
It just becomes part
of their nature.
And they feel that if they
don't meet those expectations,
that they're humiliated.
There's nothing worse
than humiliation,
especially if you
personally feel that way.
And so the philosophy
of my program
is that you work until
you get it right.
So I don't actually
even grade until you
get an A. Kids will revise
things over and over and over.
I have a mastery-based system.
So you can revise-- you
come into the program,
you don't know how
to write, so then you
revise that essay or
that article 10 times.
And in between each
revision, there is no grade.
You only get the
grade at the end.
And so I think kids need
to be given a freedom,
freedom like that to fail.
But what happens in
a lot of the programs
is that you get a
grade, and then they
average that grade
with the other grade
and then they average
the other one at the end.
You know, you can get 89.4
and you get a B, B plus.
And then your parents
get mad and whatever.
So I think there needs to
be less emphasis on grades,
more emphasis on it's
OK to make a mistake.
It's OK to be a kid.
Let's get rid of all
this high pressure stuff
and make them feel like it's OK.
So I know Gunn
High School now is
thinking about moving to what
is called the block schedule.
So [? Powie ?] has
the block schedule.
Instead of having every
period on every day, all seven
periods, we go period, that's
two, four, six on one day
and one, three, five,
seven on another day.
And then one day a week,
we have all periods.
And it's interesting,
the kids are now
complaining that the one
day a week for all periods
is too stressful.
And it might be because
the pressures are
so high to get into college.
Also one other thing
I wanted to mention
is that they all want to
go to Harvard, Princeton,
it's ridiculous.
So I've been giving
them stories.
I just brought in Mike Honda,
Congressman Mike Honda.
Do you know who he is?
He's a local congressman.
He did really poorly
in high school.
He actually dropped
out of college.
In general, he was not academic
and then he did super well.
And now he's been
a congressman for I
don't know how many years, 20
years, something like that.
But it's just to give
them some perspective.
You don't have to go to Harvard.
You know you can go
to Foothill College.
You can go to any
school or you don't even
have to go to school maybe, if
you want to do something else.
You need to think about
what you want to do.
So more teachers
have to say that.
Because they don't
listen to their parents
when they're teenagers.
Sorry to shock you.
But anyway--
JAMIE CASAP: But it's
all part of this whole--
we talked a little bit
about earlier, this idea
that it's an individual sport.
And not only that, we make them
compete against each other,
right?
So they are competing
for grades and sometimes
instead of figuring out how to
collaborate, they're competing
and that causes issues.
ESTHER WOJCICKI:
That causes issues
and especially if teacher
grades on a curve,
you're just grading
on an absolute scale,
and certain number kids get
an A and then another B,
and then they talk
about grade inflation.
And then kids are
checking their phone.
I'm not kidding.
They check their phone
every 20 minutes.
I don't post grades.
It's like, finished.
Sorry, guys.
Just learn and then when you're
done doing that learning,
you can get an A and
then they're actually
very happy about this,
to be honest, no stress.
JAMIE CASAP: It's
constant iteration
versus having some absolute time
where you get a B, like what
does a B mean, right?
What do you do with a B
versus continuously learning
to iterate.
ESTHER WOJCICKI: I think
more and more programs
need to be like that.
And I think that Gunn
High School could benefit.
JAMIE CASAP: Well, most
high schools can benefit.
ESTHER WOJCICKI:
Right, most schools
can benefit, not just Gunn.
AUDIENCE: First, I
want to thank you
for what you were just saying
about stress on the kids.
I have teenagers applying
to college right now.
But my question is
actually about how do you
apply some of this in a state
like my home state of New
Mexico, where the
poverty is so great,
the biggest barrier to learning
a lot of these kids face
is just basic hunger.
The teachers are
bringing in food
to feed the students so they
can learn, that kind of stuff.
How do you apply the
project-based learning
to a school that can't afford
any technology whatsoever
and can't even afford
to get the heat working?
JAMIE CASAP: That's
a great question.
ESTHER WOJCICKI: That's
JAMIE CASAP: You take it.
I'm not taking it.
This is your show, not mine.
ESTHER WOJCICKI: My
very first teaching job,
I had a class full of boys
period one in the morning.
And that was their number one
problem, they were hungry.
And I was in San Leandro and,
you know, it's a major problem.
It's too bad that the-- you
know, somebody in the community
has to solve the problem.
I solved the problem by
bringing in food every day.
And then the
administration wanted
to know what I had done
to make these boys learn.
And it was just so simple,
just food in the morning.
So it's very hard to
learn when you're hungry.
And it's also hard to learn
when you don't have a place
to live or stay.
We have a lot of
homeless kids in America.
JAMIE CASAP: Let's make
that we're clear here,
that blended learning or
project-based learning
is one component of a
giant scope of things
that we have to do in education
in terms of a learning model.
But you asked a
great question, which
I'll kind of create more
of a general question
around this, which is the use
of technology in education,
we're seeing an increase of the
use of technology in education.
Some schools can afford it,
some schools can't afford it.
But more importantly, you did
not take technology and just
put it on top of old
learning models and do that.
You actually embedded and
integrated the technology
in education.
So a lot of times, we see
technology as this nice
to have, because we're adding it
on top of things, versus being
a core enabling capability
to new learning models that
get you to that motivation
that you want from kids.
So talk about the role of
technology in education
then what you're seeing
good and also bad.
ESTHER WOJCICKI: So good is
when it's embedded in a way
that it supports the learning.
It's bad when it just continues
to reinforce worksheets.
And when kids are
just put on a computer
nonstop for, I'm not kidding,
long periods of time,
it can be for hours.
JAMIE CASAP: Drill and kill.
ESTHER WOJCICKI: Drill and kill.
That is not a good model.
And I don't know if you
know, but in Florida they
have had some problems
with the tech-based schools
because the kids were just
put on the computer all day,
and then they didn't
learn anything.
And that's one of the
other problems with MOOCs.
You know MOOCs, massive
open online courses?
People don't like
to learn alone.
Nobody wants to learn alone.
Their dropout rate is 95%.
So if you put it in a
classroom where then kids
are talking and interacting
with each other,
then they want to stay.
So my question on
those is, can you do it
online as opposed to in person?
JAMIE CASAP: The key
message is that we
have to figure out ways to
take technology and support
and enable these great
learning models that
are being created that you
champion and are part of.
ESTHER WOJCICKI:
That's what teachers
need to learn in their
professional development, how
to take technology and use it
to support their teaching, not
in place and just to make a huge
difference to get kids excited.
I think it needs-- it makes a
huge difference for America.
JAMIE CASAP: We've got
two more folks here.
Let's make sure-- I want to
get everybody's questions
in before we run out of time.
So come up and
ask your question.
AUDIENCE: Quickly, I'm
curious about your experience
with how much guidance to
give the groups of kids
when they break out into their
own independent assignments.
Do you just give
them a task and let
them completely
self-organize or do
you come in after a few
minutes and give some guidance?
I know from my team
working at Google,
many times we're challenged
on how to collaborate together
with our peers.
ESTHER WOJCICKI:
That's a good question.
So what I do, first, I just let
them pick their own partners,
by the way.
Some teachers tell
you who to be with you
and then they don't
want to do that.
So you pick your partners
and you have your project.
And then I come around
usually, and I'm like,
so what did you
guys decide to do?
And can you explain to me
why is this a good idea?
I don't just leave them in
the infrastructure is there.
It's just that I give
them more responsibility.
JAMIE CASAP: And you let them
make decisions as well, right?
You and I have
talked about, there's
been controversial articles
that the students wanted
to write about and
you guide them,
but you don't tell
them what to do
or how to position something.
You give them the
framework to do that.
ESTHER WOJCICKI: 100%.
If they'd be here, they
would tell you themselves
that they feel so
empowered that they tell me
they are in charge of the
whole class, everything.
Because they feel that way.
But in fact, I meet
with them all the time
and give them suggestions.
So every day after school or
maybe at lunchtime or something
like that, email.
But I'm not the parent, see,
so they're not threatened by--
and also I make
them as suggestions.
I don't say you have to do this.
I mean that is really the key.
And so with groups
here at Google,
I would go around and
talk to them often.
I mean one thing that's great
about Google, great people.
I mean I don't think I've
met a single person at Google
that I wasn't impressed with.
You guys are all amazing.
So I'm sure that--
JAMIE CASAP: We're doing OK?
ESTHER WOJCICKI: Yeah, you seem
to be doing just fantastically.
JAMIE CASAP: We're going
to wrap it up in a minute,
so think about how you
want to close this out.
One, we got- oh no, I'm talking
about the guy behind you.
AUDIENCE: At least I'll
be quick with my question.
Could you comment
on if there are
other parts of the world,
that are already embracing
this type of learning?
And second, about
higher education,
is this applicable to that also?
ESTHER WOJCICKI: Oh, my
god, higher education, they
should be doing this now.
JAMIE CASAP: We
failed on that one.
ESTHER WOJCICKI: Oh my
god I'm targeting K-12.
But universities, I mean why
aren't they doing this now?
Actually, Stanford
is working on it.
I've been working with
some people at Stanford.
But all universities
should be doing this.
It's hard to believe.
JAMIE CASAP: Any other
parts of the world?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ESTHER WOJCICKI: So
Mexico, they ordered
hundreds of these books.
So I'm meeting with the
Mexican Education Minister
in the end of April.
And they want to
translate it to Spanish,
which I think is terrific.
But right now, they're
ordering them all in English.
And I hope all those
teachers can read then.
JAMIE CASAP: And
also, I don't know
where the person who
asked the question is.
In some cases, you look at a
country like India for example,
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JAMIE CASAP: Even if they had
all the resources in the world
to build all the schools
that they wanted,
they'd still be short
anywhere between 500,000
700,000 teachers that they
need to fill those classroom.
So in some cases, they have
to come up with some new model
to teach because the one
to 30 model isn't going
to work in a place like that.
ESTHER WOJCICKI:
So also actually I
should just tell
you other countries
that have come through.
So Indonesia was just visiting.
France, there have been a
lot of people from France.
Switzerland is interested.
I'm going to be
the keynote speaker
at some digital
conference in Zurich.
Germany, there is
a lot of interest.
And so all over
the world there's
a lot of interest in all
of this that's going on.
And people are trying to do it.
I think they might
have harder times
in some places of the world than
here, because the education is
more rigid than it is here.
And I've also been
invited to Korea
and I think that would
be really interesting.
JAMIE CASAP: That's an
interesting experience.
ESTHER WOJCICKI: Oh, my god.
Everybody studies.
JAMIE CASAP: Everything in my
body tells me not to do this,
but go ahead, James.
You get the last question.
AUDIENCE: A fun final question.
If Susan, Janet and Anne
were going to school today,
how would you approach parenting
any differently than you did
back when they went to school?
ESTHER WOJCICKI: My god, what
a bonus question that one is.
What would I do?
JAMIE CASAP: You're
supposed to say,
I wouldn't do
anything different.
I did everything perfectly.
ESTHER WOJCICKI: Yeah.
I'm not sure.
I'm not sure about that.
So a lot of people ask me,
would I control their time
with technology?
I think I probably
would do some control.
And I would control what they
are doing online, as opposed
to, I wouldn't let them
just do anything online.
I would do that.
People also ask me what did I
do to make them so independent?
Boy they are really independent.
And I think the main thing
I did is, I didn't have
any help when they were small.
It was just like me
and the three kids.
And my husband is a high energy
physicist, professor of physics
and his main interest
in life is particles.
And so he spent a lot of
time thinking about those.
And so, I was like, oh, my
god, what am I going to do?
So what I did is
like, OK, you guys,
you can walk in you
can talk a little,
you're going to be on the team.
You're going to be doing
a lot of stuff early.
And so, that's exactly right.
They all had responsibilities,
a lot of them, early.
And I think that
made a difference.
Poor Susan was responsible
for taking care of Janet
when she was two.
Wasn't really, I mean I didn't
leave her alone in the house,
but you know, she
had to entertain her.
JAMIE CASAP: Had a role.
ESTHER WOJCICKI: She had a role.
And that continued
all through school.
JAMIE CASAP: Well,
unfortunately we're out of time.
So hopefully we can give
Esther a round of applause.
Thank you very much for
coming and talking to us.
[APPLAUSE]